[Music]
wow
[Applause]
hello welcome back to Hannity we are
back with our life us us us USA we are
back with our live studio audience thank
you all for coming thank you for joining
us at home uh these are the only normal
people in the entire state of New York
they're right here in this room uh thank
you all for coming thank you for being
with us now uh you're now looking at
images right here in New York City
tonight not the crowd hate and hysteria
is now spreading around the globe at a
rapid Pace this is what happens when the
world is the void of American leadership
and this is the result when you elect a
frail weak cognitively struggling
president and they have a effectless
Administration the Middle East is now
officially a powder keg ready to blow
riots are now erupting outside US
embassies abroad with widespread
chanting of death to Israel death to
America America's the greatest devil the
US Embassy in Beirut Lebanon Under Siege
with American Personnel having to flee
that country massive riots also erupting
in Turkey including again outside the US
Embassy uh there we have more protests
in Baghdad in Iraq in Paris in London in
Germany we have seen virulent
anti-Semitism worldwide the likes of
which I never thought we'd see In Our
Lifetime and meanwhile at home what uh
Democrats would call an Insurrection
actually broke out of our nation's
capital today at the capital complex you
had multiple riers assaulted arrested
for assaulting police after clashes with
those law enforcement now this after a
truly unhinged deeply dishonest rant
from one of America's
most notorious bigots the virulent
anti-semitic congresswoman to leave now
this is after all the evidence that
proves that the hospital in Gaza was not
the fault of Israel take a look at this
watch people think it's okay to bomb a
hospital for
[Music]
children you know what's so hard
sometimes is watching those videos
and and the people tell me the kids
don't cry I'm like let them
cry and they're shaking and somebody you
know this they keep telling them not to
cry in
Arabic they just they can cry I can cry
we all can cry if we're not crying
something is wrong don't let her
crocodile tears fool you because
congresswoman TB is stoking the Flames
of anti-Semitism and hatred uh and by
the way where were were her tears when
defenseless Israelis were slaughtered uh
the the biggest terror attack in the
history of Israel when babies were
killed when babies were beheaded when
they were kidnapped where women were
kidnapped and raped and taken hostage
many killed where were the tears then
you know where was congresswoman to
leave at that point and where were other
people on the left you know they they
had now become mouthpieces for Hamas the
terrorist organization they have in
their Charter the destruction of Israel
they're out there spreading lies
propaganda misinformation at a rapid
pace so let us be clear tonight Israel
Israel did not bomb that hospital in
Gaza the IDF has said so and they have
presented to the world all the evidence
that is
incontrovertible that it was the result
of a misfired rocket intended for Israel
from the other one of the other Terror
groups in Gaza the Islamic Jihad us
intelligence yes they say the same exact
thing and they have confirmed Israel's
claims now
geolocated uh video published by Al
jazer shows the Rockets being launched
from right inside of Gaza with one
rocket straying off course you can
follow it and in the direction of the
hospital followed by an explosion a
short time later and then there is this
audio published by the IDF which which
purportedly features a conversation
between two Hamas operatives and they
have confirmed it
listen
subh yeah
know what's sad because the world uh so
quickly raced to judgment and blamed
Israel Israel had to defend itself you
know what I think they would have
preferred not to tell their enemies
about their intelligence gathering
capability but they had to you want more
evidence you got it at the apparent
point point of impact there was no
significant crater a minimal Blast Zone
a few cars were destroyed in the
immediate area but other vehicles just a
few feet away they were left totally
intact in other words the explosion had
none of the trademark characteristics of
a large guided Israeli missile and all
the characteristics from a
unsophisticated terrorist rocket and
thankfully based on these images the
hospital was not destroyed and suffered
only at worst minimal damage and it is
highly unlikely that 500 people died as
claimed by members of Congress by the
media mob uh and by everybody else
worldwide it's sad but that's the world
we're living in that has not stopped
America's anti-semites from using that
explosion caused by the Islamic Jihad to
vilify Israel and fan the Flames of War
this tweet from congresswoman to leave
it's still up there Israel just bombed
the Baptist Hospital killing 500
Palestinians just just that really this
tweet from uh Omar congresswoman Omar is
also still up quote bombing a hospital
is among the gravest of war crimes the
IDF reportedly blowing up one of the few
places the injured and wounded can seek
medical treatment and shelter during a
war is horrific not only are these
tweets still active but neither
congresswoman is willing to condemn the
group actually responsible the terrorist
group Islamic Je
now these are sick hateful dishonest
people who are implicitly rooting for
death and destruction what inside Gaza
so they can show the world how evil
Israel is as everybody remember the
victim here was Israel they didn't want
this war they they didn't start this war
they don't even want to fight the war
but they have to defend themselves sadly
the mob and the media they're no better
in a series of bizarre retweets uh NBC
idiotic so-called disinformation
specialist some guy named Ben Collins
racing and rushing to blame Israel for
the explosion you know quickly passing
off Hamas propaganda as fact the New
York Times They did the exact same thing
paring the lies and the misinformation
and the talking points from terrorists
so did the AP so did Reuters so did
Bloomberg so did fake news CNN look at
this headline quote hundreds killed an
Israeli strike on Gaza Hospital
Palestinian officials say Palestinian
officials okay who elected Hamas uh the
people in in in Palestinian people voted
for them in what 2006 their last
election the media mob was taking the
word of Hamas only minutes after the
explosion their rush to judgment forced
Israel to give away some of their
greatest intelligence gathering
information and their tactics and
techniques not a good idea the same
barbarians by the way who just uh
perpetrated the worst terrorist attack
in Israel's history beheading babies
raping women burning families alive the
same terrorists who are keeping hundreds
of men women and children hostage and
parading them on the Internet to torture
their families and by the way among the
hostages are our fellow American
citizens as our fellow Americans were
also killed is that what the Associated
Press calls quote journalism
now over at
msdnc I don't you probably have never
heard of this guy he's a little
pipsqueak he has a show apparently um
his name is Chris Hayes you ever hear of
Chris I never heard of the guy he's
dumber than fake Jake at fake news CNN
that's how dumb he is now I wonder if
little Chrissy is proud that it was his
own network and his own colleague Ben
Collins who were spewing Hamas
propaganda the so-called reporters
across the street at NBC News news well
they should be hanging their heads in
shame but this is the same network that
pedal lies conspiracy theories you know
about Trump Russia collusion for three
long years you know now we know
something that never happened yeah
they're the same people now remember
these are all devout Democrats they're
all Biden supporters they're all members
in good standing with the climate
alarmist religious cult and clearly the
president has lost control of the
message as the world is now spiraling
into cha
and today's what 7-hour photo op in
Israel probably didn't help Biden was
shunned by the Arab world leaders from
Jordan Egypt they refused to meet with
the president mmud abas wouldn't even
meet with Biden a humiliating Act of
defiance they would rather believe Hamas
propaganda than meet with the president
of the United States and by the way
these are the same leaders that care so
much about the Palestinian people not
one of those countries is willing to
accept a single Palestinian refugee but
obviously they sense weakness from Joe
Biden and I have to be honest for good
reason he is trying to deliver an
important message in Israel you you
decide how important this is I was
deeply saddened and outraged by the uh
explosion at the hospital in Gaza
yesterday and based on what I've seen it
appears as though it was done by the
other team not not you but there there's
a lot of people out there not sure so we
got a lot we got to overcome a lot of
things the other team you mean the
terrorist Joe you know can't you do a
little the other the other team of
terrorists is that what you're saying
you can't do better than that Joe they
just blew up part of a hospital blamed
it on Israel lied about it sparking
riots and violence all around the world
but no world leader wants to meet with
you because apparently Joe can't do any
better here you know he's on Air Force
One on the way home looking half asleep
struggling to speak before telling
Palestinians to quote learn how to shoot
straight wow what advice take a look can
you talk about the impact of meeting the
survivors and the First
Responders that's all person look
I I spent an hour and a half about 17 or
18 before
and I don't know how to say
this virtually
every mass
shooting
every circumstance
where large number of people have been
victimized and lost I spoke with our
defense department it says it's highly
unlikely that Israelis would have a
different footprint and have intercepted
some
anyway and uh so that's why if you
notice I didn't say it at first I didn't
I wanted to make sure that I knew and
look and I'm not suggesting that Hamas
deliberately did it either that's that
old thing got to know how to shoe
straight uh you know and uh and it's not
the first time Hamas has
La something that didn't function very
well how scary is
that now did you notice the senior
officials grimacing oh cringing in the
background as Joe was having a hard time
putting a sentence together now more
than ever America and the world needs a
strong leader with a clear message a a
person with moral Clarity like BB
Netanyahu a president who was able to
articulate a few simple basic
fundamental truths first the Palestinian
people will never be free or safe with
Hamas in charge of Gaza second Israel
has got to defend itself and its
Homeland and destroy the terrorists who
seek the destruction of the world's only
Jewish State third the Islamic Republic
of Iran is behind all of it funding
supplying coordinating this Terror using
Palestinians as Pawns in their sick
efforts to dominate the region it would
be great if we had a president who could
articulate that message to to the world
but we don't and now we have chaos all
over the globe but fear not Joe will be
giving a prime time address tomorrow at
8 p.m. Eastern I can hardly
wait will somebody wake him up for that
little coffee maybe maybe even to
Aderall I don't know hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else